[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs de 7,8 loi dira ce
jeudi des idées sorties pour conclure
ces vacances de février tout de suite le
sommaire de cette semaine des sièges en
forme de bouche des fauteuils comme des
vestiges au musée de la ville les sièges
sur des volts une exposition leur est
consacrée et des animations pour tous à
vivre en famille pour ces derniers jours
de vacances d'hiver le rombo litres à
vous accueillent pour diverses activités
et l'agenda complet de vos sorties au
programme du sport du bien-être et du
cinéma
il reste encore quelques jours donc pour
profiter de ces vacances d'hiver à
rambouillet le musée rambo litres vous
plonge dans l'histoire ferroviaire
découverte de machines historiques ou
imaginer soi même une locomotive au
regard des trouves tu que celle ci
ressemble un train pourtant sont nés
sains et ils s'appellent je prends les
soufflants antoine et son grand-père
voyage au centre durant boli train
ce livret jeu pensé par les équipes du
musée entraîne les visiteurs au temps de
jules verne
c'est facile mais des foyers des trains
contre 11,5 et qui sont un peu caché son
papa y est venu
il y a à peu près où 30 35 ans ça est
donc seul lui avait bien plus à lui
avait donné lui même le goût de faire
des maquettes puis je pensais que ça
pouvait faire plaisir mon petit fils qui
aime bien les trains chercher parmi les
milliers de trains ou même les imaginer
deux livrets sont disponibles en
fonction des âges ce vendredi 21 février
les petits visiteurs sont appelés à
imaginer leur propre locomotive
si j'étais un train est un atelier d'une
quinzaine de minutes
c'est grâce au nom de ses trains et à la
description qu'on leur donne c'est de
dessiner un train pour les plus grands
d'imaginer à quoi il pouvait ressembler
et pour les plus petits pourront coller
des gommettes donc ça c'est plutôt pour
les maternelles ils sont aidés en bien
sûr c'est un moment de partage avec les
parents ou les grandes soeurs et frères
et si le temps le permet
samedi 22 février solène prolongera le
voyage avec mini la locomotive à essence
tourne autour du musée alors adultes
comme enfants en voiture
un match à ne pas manquer celui des
templiers d'elancourt ce samedi 22
février ils affrontent les dockers de
nantes
coup d'envoi du match à 10 9 à 19 heures
au complexe sportif europe à elancourt
et vous souhaitez peut-être prendre un
peu de temps pour vous un peu de
bien-être
la piscine de saint-germain-en-laye
organise une soirée zen le jeudi 27
février plusieurs activités seront
proposées sophrologie sur le yoga ou
cours d'aqua postural l'événement débute
à 19h30 les 25 et 26 février prochains
la ferme de bel ébat propose une
nouvelle création une oeuvre interdite
lors de sa sortie toile d'araignée et
écrite par eduardo pawlowski en pleine
dictature
il est un des auteurs porteur du théâtre
politique un théâtre volontairement
provocateur la pièce raconte l'histoire
d'une famille argentine durant les
années 70 une pièce de résistance
elle s'adresse à un public averti on
écoute l'un des comédiens de cette pièce
il est lui-même argentin c'est un sujet
hyper fort pour les uns chantent en est
c'est pas quelque chose qui s'est passé
il ya énormément du temps c'est assez
récent dans l'histoire dans la mémoire
du peuple noir chantant et qui est très
vif et pour nous aussi avec les
mouvements politiques des dernières
années en argentine s'est remis sur la
table toute cette période
des fauteuils aux formes surprenantes
depuis le 5 février le musée de la ville
a sorti de ses collections des sièges
design une découverte que l'on peut
agrémenter de visites guidées et on en
parle avec notre invité frédéric
debussche bonjour bonjour vous êtes
directeur du musée de la vie déjà
pourquoi avoir choisi de mettre à
l'honneur des sièges et seulement des
sièges
alors pour plusieurs raisons on voulait
une collection très riche musée de la
ville de saint quentin en yvelines
nos 3000 objets des objets d'ailleurs
comprennent est relativement peu
puisqu'ils sont on peut montrer et la
volonté du musée justement et de vouloir
désormais davantage s'appuyer sur sur
cette collection est dans cette
collection on a notamment une très belle
collection de sièges et notamment de
sièges qui tourne autour des années 60
70 et donc il était intéressant de
cibler plus spécifiquement cette
thématique
parce que le siège aussi est un grand
sujet de design dans ces années là non
l'exposition est ciblée sur la fin des
années 60 début d incendie et le siège
le fauteuil ses déclinaisons sont
vraiment les objets privilégié des
designers à cette époque qu'est ce qu'on
peut
exposition s'appelle le siège se
révoltent oui c'est cette révolution là
oui parce que c'est une époque de
révolution donc comme je disais années
60 70 sont nées autour en fait de
l'année 68 en france ni ailleurs on est
dans une époque de grande révolution
culturelle une révolution de la société
est en fait le design tout simplement
accompagne et encourage cette révolution
notamment une révolution des moeurs fin
qu'on connaît très bien par ailleurs
effectivement
le fauteuil est un outil privilégié qui
accompagne cette nouvelle société en
train de s'installer
on le voit sur les images on a du mal à
imaginer que ce sont des sièges des
fauteuils ça dépasse le simple aspect
pratique alors dans les années 60
oui oui certains sont assez déroutant
c'est à dire qu'on sort d'un design qui
étaient fonctionnels jusque là dans les
années 50 60 ou aux privilégiés vraiment
la fonction est donc une forme qui
devait suivre lusage à partir des années
60 on se construit un petit peu en
opposition à cette génération précédente
les designers se libère et ils veulent
faire littéralement exploser les formes
traditionnelles pour en inventer des
nouvelles qui remette complètement en
cause les le design et le mobilier des
générations précédentes et donc on a des
feuilles des fauteuils pardon qui
ressemble quelquefois à tout sauf à des
fauteuils
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait une exposition
assez surprenante le 29 février les
équipes du musée propose une visite
guidée de cette exposition c'est
l'occasion d'en apprendre encore plus de
choses oui bien sûr ce cas alors il ya
une médiation déjà dans l'exposition des
textes un peu gêné rocchi qui parle du
contact social ou sociétal de l'époque
il ya également deux textes qui qui
explique plus précisément les tenants et
les aboutissants de chaque siège mais
chacun d'eux source d'un long discours
parce qu'il faut à la fois les remettre
dans une dimension
j'ai à dire presque politique mais du
moins
sociétal une dimension technologique une
dimension artistique puisque le design
est effectivement à la croisée de ces
différents domaines
on pourra aller toucher qu'avec les yeux
oui une obligation de temps qu'il y a
dans cette exposition des prêts alors
déjà nos collections sont précieuses
mais les prêts des autres collections
sont tout aussi précieux et donc on a
par exemple des des fauteuils qui
viennent du centre pompidou d'autres du
centre national des arts plastiques de
galeries privées du frac de fonds
régional d'art contemporain ou de france
donc ce sont des pièces vraiment
exceptionnel très précieuse et qui sont
fragiles parce que c'est un peu le la
caractéristique fin une des
caractéristiques des mobiles et cette
époque qui sont des mobilier moderne
mais pour autant relativement fragile et
qui peuvent aussi devenir petit à petit
ancien as oui oui je vois tu tiens qui
ont maintenant presque une cinquantaine
d'années ou qui on sera content et qui
qui sont complètement rentré dans
l'histoire
beaucoup d'entre eux sont partis
aujourd'hui des grandes icônes du design
du 20e siècle
merci frédéric debussche d'être venu sur
ce plateau alors l'exposition le siège
se révoltent elle a commencé le 5
février mais elle est à découvrir au
musée de la ville de 50 ans nommé la
première visite guidée pour en apprendre
le plus possible
prévu le samedi 29 février pour parrot
pavés du canal avec une rencontre qui
vous attend rachid benzine l'auteur de
lettres à nour sera présent à la
librairie
il y monte haine pour échanger avec les
lecteurs il présentera pour l'occasion
son premier roman
ainsi parlait ma mère est ce mercredi 19
février est sorti l'appel de la forêt là
on passe à notre page cinéma c'est un
film de voyages et d'aventurés celle de
bugs un chien au grand coeur arraché à
sa maison en californie
au casting de ce film harrison ford et
un certain omar sy patrick sève jacques
de dixmude et mathilde de 2010 ont
recueilli les avis des premiers
spectateurs
[Musique]
le yukon est un endroit dangereux
on sait jamais ce qui peut arriver
je suis monté ici parce que je ne
voulais plus côtoyé personnes et puis
j'ai rencontré bac je ne sais pas d'où
tu viens
je sais où tu aujourd'hui d'un film avec
beaucoup d'émotion de voir harrison ford
dans un rôle où il n'y pas de beaucoup
d'émotion c'était c'était émouvant
c'est émouvant même les petites qui se
sont mis à pleurer c'est serrar est
vraiment magique
le voir justement parler d'amour par
rapport aux animaux de ne pas faire du
mal c'est c'est un autre registre et
c'est pareil rare de le voir avec ce
type de rôle les images le son le
personnage la forêt en plus c'était
super
c'est plutôt à vue pour les enfants mais
des grands sont émerveillés aussi et
toutes les aventures du début jusqu'à la
fin et magnifique île aventure humaine
et l aventure animal quoi exceptionnel
mon mari seul ford
donc voilà exceptionnel et vraiment je
trouvais fallait alors beaucoup touché
c'est très ému
[Musique]
je suis content que ça te plaise
on quitte maintenant les yvelines
petites ou grandes ces boîtes imaginé
par l'illustrateur serge bloch ont
toutes le même objectif vous faire rire
depuis le 5 février son exposition au
bois tahrir a pris possession du
centquatre à paris un sujet signer deux
confrères de via grand paris m l'humour
en boîte et se retrouver dans des
situations cocasses
c'est le pari du dessinateur serge bloch
dans cette exposition aux allures
d'aires de jeux et une dizaine
d'installations avec des boîtes les plus
petites sont à la taille d'une aura
certaine on peut y mettre la tête
d'autres on rentre dans ses boîtes dans
des boîtes qui sont animés et des boîtes
qui sont en réalité augmentée tous ces
dispositifs sont des boîtes dans
lesquelles on est censé s'amuser
dessinée voit votre visage se
transformer ou vous glisser dans un
décor amusant que vous soyez ciller ou
la tête dans un cul vous devenez vous
même l'objet central du spectacle
[Musique]
aider c'est toujours que les gens soient
en scène à l'intérieur de l'expo aura
dans ses boîtes là des enfants grains de
son étude mais les habitudes des courbes
et un peu donc j'imagine que quand il y
aura une dizaine d'adultes là en train
d'écouter ce qui se passe dans les bois
que ce sera aussi amusant à voir car
entendre s'amuser sans oublier d'admirer
le coup de crayon de serge bloch
monsieur j -p ce petit personnage aux
airs de chaplin vous emmène de boîte en
boîte à travers toute l'exposition il ya
des silhouettes noires de ce petit
bonhomme quand on utilise son téléphone
les cibles s'anime on a fait une
quarantaine de petites animations comme
ça pour ce court mais ce type qui
souffrent vous avez jusqu'au 8 mars 2020
pour venir capturer vos plus beaux fous
rires au centquatre
c'est la fin de ce site choisir merci de
nous avoir suivis vous pouvez revoir
cette émission en replay sur notre site
internet où notre application se
retrouvent jeudi prochain à 18h30 pour
de nouvelles idées sorties
[Musique]
où